this week we've got high jitsu disliked
rewind and tattoo burn okay her first
story there is this martial arts
tournament ooh that it's a requirement
for you to be high oh yeah yeah yeah oh
it's the Brazilian Jiu Jitsu one yeah
high rollers [ __ ] she was
comfortable masters on opium that betide
is hella funny Oh round one what around
mantle kid there should we got drunken
kung fu tournament or you just see
everybody like [ __ ] drunk now she just
reminds me of the the the Buddhist monk
bell was [ __ ] [ __ ] people in the
ass there's a viral video that we saw
with this guy he's like in Taiwan in
Taiwan he's like this Buddhist monk but
then he has like all these gay orgies
with like old men yeah actual gay orgies
yeah just [ __ ] guy eating their ass
out and [ __ ] like they do meth in the
monastery and then they all have like
massive orgies or the temple right yeah
and then they have this bottle of Lube
that says like holy water but it's moved
yeah that's where I stopped believing
you know we'll send you the article from
a few the only water Lube bottle yeah
it's it's that temple right next to your
new dojo behind it is that one in Taiwan
in Taiwan no such a weird setup you said
it's a bottle of Lube that's holy water
but it's loop I know I said it weird but
your brain is weird sometimes okay
that's what you love me I do so yeah I
didn't catch that
damn weird knowledge just thinking a gay
monks having sex you're thinking of
monks having sex like you were
visualizing that I saw you know
airbender aimed the last avatar the blue
I saw like 50 out of those dudes [ __ ]
hating meth and like all in the [ __ ]
massive orgy just sweaty just like
animated cartoon like have you seen that
art word there's a bunch of naked people
and they turn into a shape of the skull
yeah it's a photo that's uh that's Dali
or that's having a dog oh wow yeah
that's what I pictured like a big
[ __ ] room and it's like imagine if
you get a bunch of snakes and you threw
them in the big pit just all naked old
you naked [ __ ] mono hair and [ __ ]
shape of a song they're like slithering
around and then they get up to take a
[ __ ] hit of a meth pipe Wow knows
that was the weird part for me too okay
it's like babes Oh anyway we're not
talking about that story right now we're
talking about the high rollers BJJ yeah
so you guys are saying it's all night
come on no it's not all it's it's I only
know about it because I follow
what's-his-face [ __ ] you know any bravo
Bravo so he's been talking about it a
lot and I saw a clip with these Bulls
just sorta [ __ ] they talked real
quick and they slapped you just started
rolling they're high on weed weed yeah
we meet only they it's been around for a
while so like the new BJJ community is
that in wheat is pretty synonymous
because I think like BJJ it's very like
calculative and very strategic so a lot
of these guys they like smoking because
it helps open up their mind to new moves
and stuff so like unlike a lot of
traditional martial arts where every
single move or counter has already been
invented
there are new moves invented every
single day so it's a constantly evolving
sport and then the we just unlocks it
yeah there are something that the weed
calms down the nerve yeah before the big
competition and just like it's combating
the anxiety that you feel so you're like
more relaxed so you're able to focus I
don't know if I could battle it out as
soon as I get high I'm gonna just be
running my fingers up and down my
[ __ ] partner's arm and [ __ ]
every day you start rolling like BAM
mommy your skin's kind of nice what kind
of lotion do you use that doesn't let a
homie real tacos not vacation let's go I
mean I don't mean to be gay it's just
very it's kind of like a [ __ ] bottle
I mean I don't mean to be gay
that's another shirt right there I don't
mean to be gay but you're gay it's
actually good fabric [ __ ]
wrong [ __ ] so like is it like the same
what is it like a pre-roll joint
provided it's it's the same THC content
and levels just to make sure that people
are on the same type of dosage before
they compete the level of competition
for the this is more like it's more like
exhibition bout and it's just people
come in to kind of like jam out together
so it's not it's not like a sanction
like like BJJ or whatever that means
you're almost looking for the product to
like take effect you're like kind of
almost optimizing the possibility of
like newfound movement or like that's
the whole point that's I hope you got
you versus like just doing what you
normally do hi yeah it's not like 10%
weed and a 90% jiu-jitsu it's like 50/50
at this point before people who do smoke
it it doesn't make sense to me just
because like Judas is like chess yeah
you know and so if you have high nerves
you're just [ __ ] freaking the [ __ ]
out when somebody's smothering you right
so like for me when I when I heard that
I could see how it makes sense for
people who do like wheat and it works
well with them if it caught your nerves
doubt you already have an advantage as
people who are so tensed up in jujitsu
you waste half your energy just doing
this yeah and I just [ __ ] being a
hard [ __ ] dick the whole time yeah I
mean like it's just useless yes I stand
at the prize for each Division champion
is a pound of pot it's cool that you
call the pot well that's what they wrote
in the article pound of pot that's time
when they win they're just holding it
[ __ ] huge ass [ __ ] bag
it's on one giant it's just a big pot Oh
that'd be time if it was pot and if you
or just a joint it's like a pound of pot
it's like that much really hot it's like
a full vacuum packed seal it's like that
big like how thick it's about maybe 2 or
3 inches thick how many milligrams I
don't know dude it's like some one of
the like roughest [ __ ] sports ever
you announces about this much and it's
28 I think or 27 points something or you
know I still have all the cuts where
every time we roll like I still have
these random cuts that keep opening up
out of [ __ ] nowhere okay our bites
they go away go away it's just like you
don't know where you get cut until you
take a shower after because it stings
from random place exactly do ignite like
bruises on my shoulder blades and [ __ ]
like they just started swelling up so
like after you're such a man now who are
you like that [ __ ] goes you you got cut
from like wrestling you may think I'm a
man now but you just see how I act when
I actually do it because they have to
force me to roll you're pretty good I
did it with you
no that's cute but we're talking about
rolling right it doesn't matter I mean
you're still like there's fists coming
at your face you know I try though you
know I get beat up most the time but
that's how much you thought that David
was a [ __ ] but he's always been
athletic I've said it time and time and
time again that David does not have a
dick but now so he's getting a big how
big is it right now the millimeter okay
well we'll work on that
we'll work on that it's a little cold
all that's important is that it's
growing
that's what we need to focus on right
here our next story here did you guys
hear about YouTube's rewind yeah I heard
that people don't like it which I don't
understand why because all of them have
been trash I don't know when people did
like rewind yeah like I guess like that
but it's just every year like they get
worse and worse and worse but the first
one was terrible and the second and the
third and the fourth and the 8,000 I'm
just saying it got even worse wait was
it was it Bart in one and you were like
a
zombie you were I was in a comedy week
one oh and never mind
I danced in one before in like a suit or
something I remember oh so you're like
the same years uh rewind is now the most
disliked video on YouTube it has 10
million dislike I haven't even it
surpassed Justin Bieber's baby what is
baby head so because it has so many
likes I mean been there for like what
how many years but it's like that used
to be the most disliked video until now
rewind 2018 I feel like baby it was the
first video a billion billion
I thought size was yes I was I was the
first day two billion and now is [ __ ]
baby shucks dude - dude - baby shook
that one's [ __ ] killing it
I don't know that song it's cute though
yeah it's [ __ ] love it I don't get it
either
every started that comes to it and then
mommy show that's come on oh yeah and
then daddy shot we're so we're starting
a kid songs dude that's what we're doing
you should kids are just like as soon as
tyka hears it or in the other just like
little [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] but for all the
[ __ ] thug kids dude we don't want to
[ __ ] ostracizing them out I'm gonna
show all the [ __ ] thug guys that we
don't want a little joy joy joy to talk
where's my daddy
are you my dad okay but it's true that's
why it's an eight-minute video so I have
a three-minute version here actually so
I have a shortened version here so I'm
gonna show you guys just some parts of
it here we go
I hate it I hate it already all that
whole is Will Smith come on now I'll
recognize it back I don't know I love
that guy Marcus Bradley like a song
who's that Asian guy no I only saw a
side face I didn't get to see him oh I
know Susie Susie looks like he could be
a good MMA fight with that kick-ass neck
he looks like y'all Romero I don't know
half of these oh don't make the comments
don't read the comments I've seen her
somewhere yeah she thought we did a
story on her who ASMR dude I love in
Satmar [ __ ] you know these people know I
don't listen to I don't watch any of our
videos so I must help you sleep I guess
they're doing like whatever the comments
are saying what a high production though
[Music]
are they kpop people's I don't get why
everyone hates it so much that's the
same as every other year like it's just
getting all cut well I think it did like
a popular thing they do not just hate it
this is the reason why I think for the
past several years people have
absolutely hated YouTube rewind is
because 80% of those people are not real
YouTube people yeah
they put all these like whoa Will Smith
he just started YouTube like a year ago
there's nothing that's going around a
lot right do you want to redo it sure a
celebrity in rewind a twitch streamer in
rewind a youtuber who hasn't posted a
video in nine months and a youtuber who
have made videos for almost a decade
became the most youtuber for five years
donated to Indian 9 year olds but still
not in rewind oh yeah yeah like
PewDiePie should rewind like I've seen
that long food like people that we know
like that those are real youtubers who's
been dedicated consistently these guys
kind of just blew up they came from vine
or their twitch streamers or something
like that they just look at numbers so
there's a huge disconnect from people at
YouTube and the actual people on YouTube
that are creating and constantly yeah
yeah yeah that makes sense to me
but maybe I'm just gonna think about
maybe they did contact them and anyone
do it that happens I mean that never
happened to me but I'm saying like they
did content they never contacted me cuz
I would have done it that we ruined the
whole set fans of BTS were angry that
despite all [ __ ] BTS fans tribute to
the music video for Idol that BTS
themselves were not named and that
that's like there's an ongoing belief
that fans think that YouTube is altering
BTS video views too so like they're mad
about that are BTS like a people's
youtuber no they're Korean so they're
not right there they're like made from
Korea yeah BTS fan people are dipped
like Korean k-pop fans are insane yeah
yeah you mentioned anything bad about
any type of person that they like they
freak the [ __ ] out I say one comment
about BTS I'm punishing this know you
don't know [ __ ] about B I'll give a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
think about that suck my [ __ ] nuts No
shoutout to BTS double so marques
Brownlee who was in I love that guy man
he said that the problem with YouTube
rewind is pretty simple actually the
delta between what creators slash
audiences expect and what YouTube wants
to show has never been more clear yeah
that's exactly what YouTube wants rewind
to be a couple minutes they can show to
advertisers and say look at all the
great stuff over here that you want to
spend your dollars on and he was in it
creators want YouTube you want to be a
celebration of youtubers and the biggest
best stuff on the platform that year
yeah that's exactly what that's awesome
I will say this though I don't think
people should be upset about Will Smith
because he's been [ __ ] killing it
killing it on YouTube like he's been
doing great content on YouTube so Will
Smith makes sense to me just because
he's actually embracing the whole collab
with I get you Will Smith because he's
like a legend he's done a lot and all
that but then him they put him on to the
forefront versus someone like PewDiePie
yeah who's like it's kind of its kind of
like um like the UFC fighters that got
kind of mad when Brock Lesnar came over
and he got all the limelight and given
he is an all-american state wrestler but
he's from a different platform that came
here and all that UFC fighters are like
like what about us
I could see it from a business
standpoint but I also see why YouTube
creators are also upset and what I mean
like just on that on that last note
though like if they're doing this every
single year how do you put a guy like
Peter Pan and then like the next year
what do you how do you follow up there's
a bunch of mb2 like actual youtubers
have never been in there
yeah there's youtubers with millions and
millions of views and followers and then
maybe they're never in there because you
know oh so does that streamer guy not
upload YouTube videos what a lot of
people are saying is that he uploads
highlights from his twitch stream to
YouTube and whatever is what it would
have his view counts he doesn't actually
have like YouTube created content I'm
not sure like I said I hundred percent
agree I just try to you know think about
it the other side yeah I agree 100% like
every time they do a YouTube rewind you
should put up the people that the
viewers watch and follow a lot because
that's how this platform was created a
thousand percent yeah the whole point of
rewind is to highlight
happen in the year and they're just like
they're just like being really selective
and not even what's a this is a crazy
old reference but like if if I talk with
rain made it big and Tay Zonday should
be in it for that year instead of
putting in all these other random people
I think that's well that's why you to
mate well that's why Will Smith made
census me because he blew up on YouTube
well obviously through his old following
yeah but because he has been a dedicated
youtuber yeah yeah obviously with the
team but I like his content like it's
very YouTube ask it feels YouTube yeah
yeah and I like it a lot so I thought
that Will Smith being there made sense
the twitch streamer is a little odd
alright last story this photo of a
bright tattoo under the skin that has
been my friend off it's going viral and
they're saying that this looks like it's
Photoshop like their it looks like this
tattoo is just inked that same day like
how is it that you know the top layer
burns off and it looks even more bright
under it well that's crazy yeah what
turned off doing what it was like a I
don't know you're just that looks crazy
you don't even know what Sun makeup
looks like a minor burn but then it
burned off and then like the ink is
shone bright it's gonna be a new way to
do tattoos start burning themselves
after getting tested yeah a lot of
people are saying like don't burn
yourself it hurts you get infection like
you never know what could happen and
there are a lot of people who are saying
like this is fake it was photoshopped Oh
everybody let's say that should do I
mean it makes sense cuz they they are
piercing it into like the third layer
yeah then if you do grow skin over it is
done it
it does look babe I don't know that
looks crazy yeah that's crazy
yeah and then this other person uploaded
this photo to show like no this happened
to my husband like it does happen you
have ink under the layers I thought that
was common knowledge that it goes in the
layers yeah but I guess the fact that it
just looks so brand new bleach on it is
it bleach the [ __ ] tattoo Oh a pouch
let's not find out bark let's not do
that
yeah this was going pretty viral a lot
of people are like don't burn your skin
huh don't
don't do it it's the president just
doesn't even have a color tattoo just to
try it you know what does happen just to
see what's under day what does happen if
have you guys had hell I got really dark
tan and then if you fall and then like
this in a rubs the tan up your super
lights again it's it comes back yeah
your brand-new skin and burns hurts so
bad have you guys ever burned yourself
ironing your clothes yeah we buy the
girls burn their ears their forehead
they're my daughters yeah we've burned
every that's yet it just turns black and
then the scar is there for like at least
like six seven months and I recently
burned the tip of my ear I don't know
what it looks like now but it felt like
it was a scab oh it was just like quick
second it was like and then oh it is a
quick so I gotta be careful man those
old flat irons - they suck they would
burn the [ __ ] out of here so you gotta
guess we were snow steamers gamers are
the new craze especially when you do
they work really well though oh really
they work pretty good you know what
sucks about iron sometimes like if you
don't have to fold it nice and you press
hard then to make that line like you
accidentally make a crease you don't
want but steamers is just hanging in
there yeah and also a hang I mean a dry
what the [ __ ] is it also an iron I
thought we were talking about hair [ __ ]
I was like there's the [ __ ] flat iron
that uses steam better than regular flat
iron like like a ceramic flutter yeah
I've seen your hair with steam I
actually have one how when they use a
state does it work well it does in a
case is it Teflon or ceramic no the one
that I have it like it brings your hair
in it's kind of scary
dude thinking about ironing clothes
gives me a high hey I just do it to the
dry cleaner now and I leave it at that I
don't remember the last time I iron
something I love dry cleaners man I
start getting worried like all [ __ ]
iron it's so easy in like two minutes
through them over 20 years not anymore
no that's crazy no they just uh well
they kind of sold that and still work so
it's not really retired Oh what do they
do now manager dance studio no did you
say like it's all good
at the same time my shoulder was sore so
I started going like this this is the
way you said it sounded like your
dissertation yeah what do they do magic
dance studio maybe because my arms were
crossed and I was like this yes studio I
think he's trying to drop hints he wants
to manage your dance studio can you let
him I'm he's scared for the scenes
how much you want how much you want to
bet your studio will blow up even bigger
yeah joe manchin area yep which which
one which one want you that'll manage
any your choice it has to be the one who
try to go the other one in China
specifically that your flagship one
which ones that one that's out here in
LA Monterey Park one ooh let's do it
that's the one Joe was gonna do I was
gonna manage the dough job from now moon
for 2019 really excited y'all senior
citizen pole dancing classes
boom 2018 was his term and it ends in
two weeks you guys want to come in only
the holidays are closed
[Music]